[Music]
and plot-twist news submitted by women
weed and whether that's good that's
weird
yeah whether and okay I understand a
woman I understand weed but what the
[ __ ] does weather mean good weather it's
obviously a reference we're too old for
a woman met her boyfriend 12 years after
giving birth to his child what 12 years
later down oh it's the one-night stand
and she was drunk oh but she met him
right so it was probably like she got a
[ __ ] donor all this vocabulary that my
head converted it to a sperm donor see
that's weird I listen to the content
yeah Matt guys you made it on your own
oh it's hard listen the contest I don't
get affected by words I go one of the
words so this story here
it's about Jessica mm-hmm oh yeah oh so
she's Jessica yeah Jessica with the C
and a see yeah so Jessica she was in a
UH in a relationship with another woman
she got married they wanted to have kids
they ended up going through a sperm
donor
welcome to Triple C but I don't know
come come coronation come collecting
corporation alright so they on the donor
thing it was listed at his profession
was listed as a writer musician and taxi
driver so she was like yeah my wife and
I would romantically imagine like he was
refusing me get a desk job but instead
collect stories he would get from his
cat or like when he would pick up his
cab adventures yeah I keep that in there
okay pop stars just you gotta keep that
in there yeah we're keeping it so they
had the daughter they had a daughter in
2005 I've named her April and then after
and so she carry Jessica carrying April
and then April born in April dope yeah a
lot of April's are born in April right
she born he was just born in April it
means actually why was she born in
February oh good thing we checked
thank you for double-checking so Alice
was born in 2005 and then the they had
another daughter by the same donor cuz
the original is gonna be like
genetically medically siblings siblings
yeah yeah because then the other mom
like the wife hell she carried using now
my turn yeah so then they were unfair
there were a family for about ten years
Wow that's when the wife Jessica's wife
was like hey you know what this marriage
is over there's no fixing this [ __ ] in
them and then like they just just bounce
and then she ended up keeping the
younger daughter during one of the
visits or whatever's one well the
daughter that she held the other wife
so then Alice
with so they split them up yeah so fun
year so then Jessica was just like she's
really sad obviously because she that
was her daughter too and then Alice just
been like so heartbroken that she lost
her sister and then so one day she Ellis
was asking her grandmother actually
wanted to know more about her past and
like you know her ancestry and stuff and
so they did the DNA test 23andme oh [ __ ]
and then they found her father
we found her father the donor and and
then they also found a brother oh cool
he's been [ __ ] common a lot
he probably like 700 [ __ ] kids
okay yeah yeah donating all that calm so
he donated a healthy lobe up three times
a week for a whole year
oh my god he's estimating that like
based off of like probability of giving
like people actually having kids through
his sperm and all this he might have
about 67 kids out there very specific
man 67 who's like Ganga scum you know a
lot of Asians have some like DNA that
his Linea cuz he [ __ ] so much and pop
so many babies out so like if he has 67
kids out there
[Music]
yes so then uh so then they were talking
to that brother whose name is Bryce that
he it was like 25% match half brother it
was 50% match for the father and his
name was her Nate his name is Aaron and
he lives in Seattle and then so that's
when Jessica went online and tried to
narrow down the actual father online to
see family and then she did she found
him and she sent a message and right
away he responded he were just saying oh
you know like I'd love to meet you guys
whatever and they started having a
connection so she's not lesbian no more
umm no cuz now they're dating oh but it
happened after like sometime because
they first met and it was for like you
know her daughter to meet her dad and
like dad's other kids and apparently her
he has up to eight children on his own
no no no from donating he never had any
like purpose it was all through donating
he has about eight he never had any for
free yeah y'all got paid for them you're
like a hot come hooker yeah now like
that should be your [ __ ] shirt next
on but a Megamall down come on all of
her shirts no one people will love it
but no will be able to wear upon be like
a pajama shirt or something yeah but all
their husbands are gonna buy that ship
for their wives oh yeah I'm surprised
she did so much research because at the
sperm bank can't you just ask a request
I know these were they chose
specifically the type of donor that they
have no relationship with the like they
don't want any like everything
they don't have a name they don't even
have a photo of this dude oh the hug was
it linked to this guy huh how was it
linked to the dead dude me oh so it was
pointless it was gonna get discovered
anyway well they know that 12 years ago
they now 20 she was donating a 19 thing
before she got she gave birth in 2005 so
that means he did 23andme then no no
well okay well not necessarily like a
dad doesn't have to do it if there's
like a bunch of siblings and they all do
it because if they know you're linked
yeah lineage nobody he popped up though
okay yeah cuz his name right [ __ ]
Edward whatever scissors Aaron one yeah
that's crazy that's not that's dope that
is nuts
literally nuts a lot of nuts I know that
fool wanted to be a phantom daddy and
now he's like got a really be a daddy
well he loves yeah he looks like an
actor oh it could be a family really our
family what are you talking about a
family they got to be a family without a
filed biological family but like an
actual like yeah well that's what she
just goes riding in her and the article
is really beautifully written cuz she
was like you know I fell in love with
him before I even met in because I got
to know me never like know him through
my daughter like I see my daughter's
traits in him so much and so she was
like meeting him felt like I was meeting
someone familiar already that's tight I
wonder if that tied some type of
biological thing in her like we're
having the child it's like BAM
automatically she feels this closeness
like I think it could she did say like
initially though when they first met
that they were because she had a
boyfriend and who was coincidentally
also named Aaron but Aaron yeah although
she was already by she had a boyfriend
right yeah I guess so Oh kid ozbaby yeah
the baby and so she was saying that like
initially like the Aaron dad was kind of
making a joke like oh they did a mix up
in the boyfriend Department
she was in her head she was just like
hold on this is just for my daughter
like I don't know about meeting you
but then like after getting to know him
more like she saw a lot of her daughter
in him and then like they just kind of
like it black hole and then she actually
moved to Seattle they don't see exactly
where she's from but they says Midwest
somewhere and so she moved to Seattle to
try to like be closer to him and then
the two kids I make you babysit a [ __ ] I
didn't even really makes a lot of babies
yeah he does those all of his kids look
good they all have the same nose yeah
and then like the same litter but was
that like a festival for him looks just
like him yeah all 67 kids get to like
come and hang out a party no they only
know of eight oh no so they did they're
a big party or not big but like he
invited everyone that he mute like he
knows like even his ex-girlfriend's and
like their families and like oh he threw
this whole rooftop party thing to meet
his kid handle and then so they also did
these games together to get to know each
other like oh do you love pickles or
whatever and then that's wild damn in
caveman terms this was the king yeah
he's made so many babies he has but it
was unfortunately by himself in a
[ __ ] white room yeah so he missed
that on all the good I know he didn't
get to do all the good stuff he just got
all the results yeah he didn't get no
[ __ ] huh he didn't he's just [ __ ]
coming in a cup
yep you didn't bust no nuts no I know
but it's such a cute story it's a really
cool story yeah so now how romantic
they're dating oh and then also they
have so she calls them his bio kid cuz
they also yeah the bio kids but then my
last babies they all live in the same
building
in his building like there was vacancies
and so she moved in with her daughter
and then the day
and now you get to charge them rent make
money off them no it's like an apartment
building they have their own apartment
crazy and then moved into the same thing
and then the sounds really cool Wow yeah
like a big-ass party
[Music]
[Music]